los crecientes casos de violencia
escolar que han sucedido en Brasil
generaron preocupación en el territorio
una problemática que no era habitual en
el país sudamericano pero que sólo en
este mes han sucedido cuatro casos
diferentes el presidente de Brasil la
Silva convocó a las autoridades de todos
los niveles para analizar La ola de
ataques de la que responsabilizó a
internet y a las compañías que hacen
culto a la violencia Armada
no vamos a convertir nuestras escuelas
en una prisión de máxima seguridad que
no tiene solución No hay dinero para eso
ni es políticamente correcto humanamente
correcto ni socialmente correcto si
Tratamos de hacer eso estamos dando una
demostración de que no servimos para
mucho porque no sabemos resolver el
verdadero problema
de agua sin embargo la propuesta que
elevaron algunos sectores sobre aumentar
la vigilancia policial en las escuelas
es un asunto que divide opiniones en
Brasil
es fundamental decir que las medidas
represivas el uso de la fuerza policial
no serán determinantes para reducir la
violencia escolar necesitamos trabajar
juntos para construir un ambiente sano y
una cultura de paz en la escuela y en el
ambiente escolar
algunas personas critican tener Guardia
municipal Armada en las escuelas creo
que hay que abordar ese tema no solo en
la ciudad de cajamar sino también en el
estado de Sao Paulo vemos que la
sociedad está enferma de alguna manera y
esto permea el tema psicológico
en la reunión participaron miembros del
gabinete del Congreso el poder judicial
gobernadores y alcaldes y se
comprometieron a terminar con esta
crisis que ya ha dejado varios muertos y
heridos